yoga is the journey of the self truth
yourself to the self the bhagavad gita
hi my name is ashish sweet and i did my
bachelors of technology in electronics
and communication
i was working at two cent iit as an
intern but soon after the full stack
java development course i got a job at
orange mantra as a software engineer
with a very good salary high during my
school and graduation days i enjoyed
coding and c plus plus programming so i
decided to switch to the software
industry during the lockdown in 2020
there was an impact on our salaries so i
decided to acquire some skills as per
the market demand and to upskill myself
i did a lot of research and learned that
simplylearn is the best online bootcamp
platform the course prices were very
reasonable compared to other platforms
and the reviews were good they also
provided me with the emi option which
was convenient for me so i decided to go
for simply learn's full stack java
development program the course
curriculum was very good the best part
of the course was the faculty and their
teaching skills during the course i
learned some new technologies like
spring boot and devops which i was not
aware of before after so much practice
and hard work and with faculty guidance
i was able to crack some interviews i
decided to join orange mantra as a
software engineer
right now i'm working on various client
projects and implementing my knowledge
from the course i have always been keen
to learn new things and in the future i
want to excel in software development
and upgrade my skills in any new
technology entering my domain as i was
working i did not have enough time to
study on weekdays so mostly i used to
study early mornings and on weekends i
was assigned to development projects so
it was convenient for me to manage time
easily i was a shy person but after the
course i became more confident and
disciplined because the projects
assigned to me were challenging and i
believe it helped me in my personal
growth as well i have been a fitness
enthusiast since my college days and in
my free time i like to utilize that time
by swimming and yoga work hard and enjoy
the young me and discipline yourself
[Applause]
[Music]